vous les avez peut-être aperçus en
passant sur la 216 toute une famille de
géants de paille ces immenses sculptures
éphémères c'est l'idée de Gérard Bodin
agriculteur à la retraite pour
sensibiliser le public à son métier une
initiative créative qui l'a eu en 2004
mais qu'il avait interrompu il y a deux
ans elles ont donc fait leur grand
retour cette année sur un terrain mi à
disposition par la commune de La Roche
Clermont Aurélie Renaud est allé les
admirer de près
Marie-Claude et Gérard était céréalier
aujourd'hui à la retraite ils ont gardé
un tracteur pour mettre en place des
sculptures de paille chaque été
aujourd'hui ils ont mis en scène toutes
leurs familles l'idée leur est venue il
y a quelques années en vacances en
Dordogne ils avaient été inspirés par
une sculpture de paille en bord de route
faire ça chez nous mais on va essayer de
le faire différemment qu'il était posé
au sol et moi je dis je vais surélever
et puis ben en 2006 on a commencé et
puis vu le succès que les gens
arrêtaient tout ça les photos qui
prenaient tout et puis on trouvait les
petits mots dans les ficelles il va
falloir qu'on commence l'année prochaine
combien
une journée et demi
chaque jour à deux pas de cette
départementale de la roche-clermo les
chinonnées et les touristes sont
nombreux à s'arrêter pour prendre
quelques photos
de travail mais bon c'est le résultat
est fascinant donc
on a envie de s'arrêter c'est sûr parce
qu'on se rend compte que justement avec
de la paille et
quelques idées de créativité on peut
faire vraiment des belles choses
Marie-Claude et Gérard ont confectionné
une petite cabane celle du livre d'Or ou
chacun peut glisser un petit mot ah ça
c'est les enfants super cool les
sculptures trop géniales bravo à vous
c'est mignon ça quand c'est des enfants
aussi ça fait plaisir tous ces
commentaires je peux vous dire que
mon mari il allait rarement aux yeux
parfois va chez ce qu'ils disent c'est
c'est ma récompense les géants de paille
seront démontés vers le 15 septembre
d'ici là le couple se laisse le temps de
réfléchir à une nouvelle thématique pour
l'été prochain peut-être une
moissonneuse-batteuse c'est l'un des
coups de cœur des admirateurs
[Musique]